playing for the audience what that sign  is all about  well  that sign is about uh  open border  yeah you know  every country protect the the  the country the people by the border  every country have a border why  biting up in the border  but you're you're you understand that at  the border  thousands upon thousands of people are  getting detained every single day and  thousands of people are being deported  so we're enforcing the border just maybe  not as much as you would like  well  i don't think i don't think a thousand  people is a departure i think nobody's  deported right now yes thousands of  people being deported  before but no no no under under joe  biden  can you imagine